that delicious
buttery
flaky crust
that creamy chicken filling chicken pot
pie is the ultimate comfort food and
after weeks of testing
many heated debates in the tasty kitchen
and buying out all the most popular
frozen chicken pot pies we now have the
most perfect homemade chicken pot pie
recipe just for you
[Music]
talk chicken there are many options you
can go with to save time you can opt for
a store-bought rotisserie chicken that's
already been seasoned for you it's easy
it's fast and it's a popular shortcut
that many people use but to us
roasting the chicken and making the
stock from scratch is a must
chicken is the base of our recipe and we
want to start on the right foot by
flavoring our dish from the very
beginning we recommend picking the
highest quality chicken you can find it
will have the best flavor and will also
make the best stock we're going to start
by patting the chicken dry with some
paper towels to remove all of that
excess moisture on the chicken if you
skip this step the skin is going to be
way too wet and all your butter is going
to slide right off alright the cavity
i'm adding one tablespoon of kosher salt
because fun fact the best way to season
your chicken is from the inside out
please don't skip this step now we want
to make sure our chicken is nice and
seasoned on the outside we love the
combination of butter garlic powder
black pepper
thyme and lemon zest
so good it's important that the butter
is room temperature so everything mixes
together really easily if you try to use
cold butter it won't even combine now we
got this beautiful compound butter let's
rub it all over the chicken make sure
you get under the skin get every nook
and cranny you can even like push it a
little bit like this to get to the outer
parts then we're going to rub the thighs
and the chicken breasts as well your
chicken should be evenly coated with
your butter mixture on the inside and
outside for having trouble getting the
butter under the chicken just stick your
finger in there to loosen the seal
between the chicken breast and the skin
making sure you get every nook and
cranny i know this is a little weird but
just embrace it this is the key to
getting the most juicy flavorful chicken
all right back to the cavity you're just
going to add your lemon quarters
chopped onion
and halved garlic this is going to help
add even more flavor and aromatics to
your chicken now it's time to tie the
chicken and we're pretty much just doing
this to help keep the moisture in so
with some butcher's twine we're going to
tie the legs together and this will help
the bird hold its shape while it's
roasting and don't forget to tuck those
cute little wings in so they don't get
burnt now we're going to transfer our
chicken into a roasting pan that has a
rack in it because all the juices from
the chicken are going to drip out and
then we're going to add that to our
stock later to add even more flavor
roasting your chicken will honestly
depend on the size if it's smaller bird
roast it for about 60 minutes if it's a
larger bird roast it for about 80. you
want to insert your thermometer in the
thickest part of the chicken thigh and
if it reads 165 it's done let it rest
for at least 20 minutes this is going to
help the meat reabsorb all its juices
because nobody wants a dry chicken now
it's time to break down the chicken so i
can use the bones for the stock and the
meat for my filling first what you're
going to do is take off one of the
thighs this is the easiest part to get
off first and it really should just pull
away make sure you put that skin in your
stock pot because we're going to use it
to make this amazing stock and fun fact
chicken skin actually has a ton of
collagen and will add a lot of flavor to
our stock all right so take the meat off
the chicken shred it into small pieces
put the meat in one bowl and add the
bones to your stockpot so to get the
breast off we're going to take the tip
of our knife and run it from the top of
the breastbone to the bottom and this is
going to help separate the breast meat
from the bone if you're worried about
getting it off in one piece honestly it
doesn't matter because we're gonna shred
it anyways and we're just trying to get
the meat away from the bones we can use
it to make stock you can see we have
some big chunks and we have our little
chunks we like to shred it into half
inch pieces so every bite has like the
perfect amount of chicken ratio to gravy
to veggies but you know what do you hear
if you want some chunks leave some
chunks once all your chicken is nicely
shredded just transfer it to an airtight
container and keep it in the fridge
until you're ready to use it now i'm
going to take this chicken carcass and
put it in our stock pot now it's time to
make our stock again we're doing it from
scratch it really just is the best way
to do it it will add so much flavor to
the filling and really enhance your dish
we tested it in a stove and a pressure
cooker there wasn't a difference in
taste but it was much faster in the
instant pot about a quarter of the time
it took on the stove so today we're
going to save some time and use the
pressure cooker if you don't have one
don't worry about it just simmer it on
your stove for four to six hours it will
still taste delicious i promise so to
the stock you're going to add onions
this one's literally a must don't skip
it garlic my personal favorite
carrots
celery peppercorns fresh thyme and
parsley and lastly a bay leaf now we're
just going to pour some water into our
pot for us this took about 12 to 16 cups
just make sure your chicken carcass is
covered by at least one inch of water
and that secret ingredient you cannot
forget add in those juices from roasting
your chicken if you're wondering where
the salt is i hear you but don't add
salt before you cook your stock you
never know how much the stock is going
to reduce and you don't want it to be
overly salty how easy was that to make
homemade chicken stock we're just gonna
cook it on high for 45 minutes and then
strain it ah the pie dough the buttery
flaky goodness that makes many believe
the crust may actually be the star of
this recipe this caused some controversy
on the tasty team there are two kinds of
people in this world
those that like their pot pie with both
a top and bottom crust and those that
just want a top crust yes those are the
things we fight about here at tasty
we've actually covered a bunch of
different crusts in one of our previous
tc 101 videos how to make the perfect
pie go check it out if you want to see
those tests to figure out how we came to
the conclusion to make an all butter
crust to make our crust we're going to
start with some all-purpose flour add a
little bit of salt and give it a mix so
next add some very cold cubed butter and
give it a toss we want to make sure each
piece of butter is evenly coated in
flour before we start breaking it down
you need to use cold butter here if it's
warm it will melt and you won't get
those beautiful flaky layers a lot of
recipes tell you to make butter into pea
sized pieces but i personally like to
just smash the butter in between my
fingers to create lima bean size butter
lima bean size pieces will actually
result in a flakier crust than if you
did pea-sized pieces don't stress about
it if all the pieces aren't even sized
we just want it to be bigger rather than
smaller so now you're going to begin
incorporating your ice water and vodka
mixture add the mixture a little bit at
a time and use a rubber spatula to toss
it all together to evenly combine vodka
is our secret ingredient here there's
some science going on it helps create
flakier layers and actually inhibits
gluten formation which can be a blessing
if you accidentally overwork your dough
so continue tossing your mixture
together just until it comes together
you don't want it to be too wet and you
don't want it to be too dry it should
look just like this when you squeeze it
in your hand still nose too dry if it
starts to crumble when you roll it out
and if it's too wet it's going to be
like a sticky tacky dough and you just
want to avoid that dough can be
intimidating but it just takes practice
just keep going at it and you'll finally
get the rhythm of it great the dough
looks good it's awesome you might be
thinking this looks super dry don't
worry you saw when i squeezed it in my
hand it came together it's going to do
that exact same thing as we start to
form it gently shape this into a
rectangle then we're going to fold it in
thirds
turn it 90 degrees flatten it fold it in
thirds again this folding technique is
much like the lamination process you see
in croissants and biscuits that help you
get those extra flaky layers since team
two layer crust one our super official
tasty bowl let's divide our dough into
two
look at these layers those are the
layers you dream about at least i do
take your two dough babies wrap them
tightly in plastic stick them in the
fridge we recommend chilling your dough
for at least one hour but you can
actually do this the day before or even
up to three days let's talk filling to
me there is nothing worse than a dry pot
pie you need the golden ratio of veggies
to chicken to sauce so we're going to
start by melting the butter in a large
pot over medium heat we like to add
onions
carrots potatoes and fresh thyme you can
totally experiment with other vegetables
like parsnips or butternut squash or
leeks or beets but we went with more of
a classic version we're gonna season
these veggies with one teaspoon of
kosher salt and we're just gonna cook it
until the onions start to soften about
five minutes after it's softened we're
gonna add the flour and we wanna keep
stirring so it evenly incorporates into
the flour and there's no lumps this will
take like two to three minutes be
patient and do not turn that heat up if
you let the rube run too much you could
change the color of your filling or even
worse burn it and then you have to start
over
slowly whisk in the chicken stock a
little at a time you want to make sure
that the chicken stock is room
temperature so it evenly incorporates
into your roux if you try to add cold
liquid to hot roux it's going to seize
up and create a lumpy filling nobody
wants that so remember patience is key
let it simmer until the stock has
reduced into a nice thick sauce that
coats the back of your spoon
for a little silky lusciousness we like
to add just a touch of heavy cream once
it looks nice and thick give it one last
stir and turn off the heat then we're
going to fold in our beautifully
shredded chicken next we're going to add
in the frozen peas hear me out this is
the only frozen vegetable allowed in
this dish if you try to use that frozen
veggie mix you'll end up with a super
mushy filling with no texture we folded
in some parsley for a bit of brightness
it's just a nice contrast for a rich and
creamy dish like this so now take your
filling and chill it in the freezer for
15 minutes it's time to roll out the pie
dough let it sit on your counter for
five to ten minutes just so it's a bit
easier to roll out you're going to want
to flour your surface flour the rolling
pin and flour your dough then gently
roll out the dough give it a quarter
turn
keep rolling and keep repeating it's
okay if it doesn't look perfect we're
going to trim the edges later both of
our doughs rolled out to about a 12 inch
circle we want the bottom one just a
little bit thicker so it's sturdy enough
to hold our filling the best way to move
your pie dough is really just roll it up
on your rolling pin then it's time to
put it in your pie dish we like to use a
glass pie dish it heats evenly and you
can see what's happening metal conducts
heat a bit better but it might leave you
with a burnt crust and we don't want
that so drip your dough over the pie
dish let it naturally find its place and
then you can make any adjustments press
down the sides and make sure there's no
air bubbles and make sure it's really
deep down touching all the sides of the
dish before you add your filling we have
another trick egg wash you just want to
brush the inside of your crust with some
of it it's going to act as a protective
layer and prevent you from getting a
soggy crust now that your crust is in
you're gonna add your chilled filling
just even it out so it's in a nice even
layer gently drape your remaining pie
dough over the pie trim off any excess
then pinch the edges of the crust
together roll it under and seal it
together then crimp it around the sides
just like this all right let's go with
the egg wash we want a nice even layer
oops
it's a little chunky i'm just going to
smooth this out nobody saw anything and
we're just going to cut a few vents in
the top to allow the steam to escape
make sure you do this after your egg
wash because if you egg washed now you
would just be sealing it back together
your pie is fully assembled you are
almost done can we just take a minute to
bask in this beauty all that hard work
is totally paying off but we just have
one more step we're gonna put this in
the fridge just for about 20 minutes so
it holds its shape when it bakes you
definitely don't want that butter to
melt before you bake it the grand finale
is here it is time to bake this bad boy
we like to bake our pie on the lower
third of the oven which helps to
concentrate the heat on the bottom to
ensure that crispy crust then we're
going to bake it for about 40 to 50
minutes rotating halfway through and
just like that you're done you have this
beautiful golden brown crust your
filling is bubbling and juicy it's
incredible but wait i lied i lied you
can't eat it yet you need to wait 15 to
20 minutes to let it cool down so you
don't burn your mouth really i'm doing
you a favor so it's time to get that
perfect slice some people like to go
straight in for a scoop or whatever
lands on their spoon we think you should
cut yourself a hearty slice and you got
yourself the ultimate buttery
flaky
indulgent perfect chicken pot pie
your friends and family are gonna love
you a little more after this one
[Music]
you